[Music]
it's time for you to see the
world prepare to be amazed
oh wouldn't have it any other
way it's a pinch me moment that I get to
be in this film there's nothing that
I've ever been a part of that's like
this I'm really grateful to get to be
part of this
story the truth is I'm a chocolate
maker the best chocolate in the world
where do we
start this is a joyous
movie so you're the funny little man
who's been following me I will have you
know that I am a perfectly respectable
size for an umpalumpa anba what
[Music]
now just get your back
the world of Aquaman is so big it's very
much larger than life fine flex your
muscles like any other superhero I put
my suit on one leg at a time what's up
Sam it's a new color
purple just retold in such a beautiful
and fresh
way the music is rooted in power that
comes from the soul of everyone of the
characters drink's on the
[Applause]
[Music]
house now it's
over wow it's going to be
[Music]
amazing